so welcome to council geeks I am joined
once again by polsku Vito and Ryan Daley
and we're going to talk some DC casting
pretty much focusing on the Suicide
Squad because I think we're getting a
somewhat clearer picture of what this
movie is as the thing is getting cast um
Jared Leto's Joker here's where I get
hopeful here's where I get nervous this
rings of trying to recreate sure heath
ledger now obviously we have no idea how
he's going to play and hopefully it will
be a completely different
characterization but let's just go on
paper young ish former heartthrob coming
off of a critically acclaimed roll yum
cast of The Joker kind of note for know
what we what we got when Heath Ledger
was first announced now to be fair I
think most of us wrote off he heath
ledger's the juggler when we first heard
Joe Hobbs I'm trying to keep open minded
unfortunately the problem is DC has not
earned my confidence in their castaways
thats a Marvel has so if Marvel makes a
casting choice that I'm a little bit
more yeah I kind kind of go on faith of
well they haven't given me a complete
misstep yet right DC doesn't have that
clout what we're going to have to give
him a little space my and my main
problem is in it I think it's actually a
problem with this film is that I don't
want the Joker reintroduced here I feel
like fundamentally that in to get the
Joker back into this universe you have
to do that through Batman but the thing
is is the reason they're giving us the
Joker's because they want harley quinn
and you can't introduce harley without
the joker and so you do have to put the
joker back into this world yeah in one
form or another they have cast him he
sign the contract yep and they are still
filming batman vs superman it's possible
he could appear in that movie before he
appears in Suicide Squad I hadn't heard
that his first appearance as this
character will be suicide squad maybe
that's the case but I don't know yeah my
concerns are how the character will be
used can they restrain themselves and
not make this movie about the Joker I
think that's going to be really hard
yeah but if they've cast a recent
Academy Award winner as the Joker right
there's going to be that much more
pressure to making more and more and
more of the focus I think she if they
I and make him part of the team and this
is fundamental the premise of the film
is you've got a group of superheroes who
are super villains who are granted a
pardon a federal pardon if they
participate in X number of missions that
are suicidal in nature that they're not
expected to live to survive because if
they die mmm West Captain Boomerang for
the flash to have I worry about Frank if
they survive well good job you saved the
country so yeah if they put the Joker on
that team then either the creator's
don't understand the Joker right or the
characters in charge of the Suicide
Squad don't understand the Joker in
which case I deem them too stupid to
survive and I don't want to watch time
right yeah I have a feeling if he is
more than just part of a Harley story if
he's more than that I think he will be
the antagonist I think he's what that
good idea that's why Harley is part of a
team I is because she knows going after
I could actually kind of go with that
and I figure it's gonna have to be that
because here's the other thing if I
could believe that he was going to be
more or less a cameo thing if there had
been unannounced Batman movie Batman
solo movie but there isn't that's not on
the docket anywhere so there's nowhere
else to use him you don't introduce the
Joker for a quick one up and then
literally do nothing else with him I
wouldn't be surprised if he shows up in
the Justice League movies I would not be
shocked but he's not gonna warrant he by
himself is not gonna warrant the Justice
League I came down because there's a
reason he's Batman's villa as opposed to
Superman cuz Superman can go right and
that's the end of it well so the other
big name wise would be Will Smith as
dead shot because what I've always found
the most interesting thing about
Deadshot the fact that the man has a
death wish yes this this is a character
unlike anything I have ever seen Will
Smith come close to playing right so are
we going to see a very different Will
Smith or are we going to see a very
different Deadshot's
and I think yeah either way they go
they're gonna tick off yeah some people
and see my prediction on this is that i
think that will smith what he's doing
here is he's trying to do some brand
fixing because after earth that much um
no we don't um we do have to watch it
have fun with that no you're both
invited and i think we are going to see
a different Will Smith okay I think we
are going to see a will smith who is
going to try and play this as a serious
darker version of this character I don't
think we're going to see the family
friendly version of this character thank
you even that ticket to account do you
think they'll hang on to the character
death because that for me is always the
most fascinating thing and for context
in case anyone watching doesn't know
part of Deadshot's deal and part of what
makes him so dangerous is that he he
does not care if he dies action to the
point that he will deliberately take
actions that would kill him but will
also allow him to finish the mission I
dread that we're going to lose that
which to me is what makes the character
more than a guy with a gun he is the
most unique in the most dynamic the most
entertaining of these characters so you
certainly have that um my name my my
main problem with this casting DC does
not have a lot of strong black
characters certainly not compared to
marble um they have some but they're not
as strong they're not is interesting but
they do have some and they have some on
the Suicide Squad I understand the the
idea for changing the race of a
character in order to expand to a
broader audience if you don't have that
pool to draw from spider-man doesn't
have any interesting or worth wild black
villains so you can cast Jamie Foxx's
electro I get that I'm fine with that
there are some pretty good black
characters in The Suicide Squad that
Will Smith could have played well I was
when Will Smith's name was first be bad
around before was confirmed I assumed he
was going to be black spider or yeah
black spider or bronze Tiger even the
Aquaman villain Black Manta has been a
member of the recent suicide squad
so there are other characters that I
could okay this is going in a completely
different tangent um but probably the
strongest and best black character that
DC has in their stable is the Green
Lantern Johnson's agents yeah is really
and the green ranger property has been
pretty tainted by the Ryan Reynolds
movie mm-hmm you know who could
single-handedly turn that franchise
around and get people excited for it
yeah mr. Will Smith yeah if they
announced that he was gonna be the next
Green Lantern I would buy that ticket
yeah it would be there too so so who
else wit well we've got Tom Hardy as
grey flag which kind of would kind of
feel like a no-brainer he's not the most
nuanced character I mean maybe they'll
find something interesting with him but
I I almost think it's a waste of his
talent I just I was aside from what I
think Tom Hardy canoe in the part I was
very surprised that they cast him again
he's on just after in the same universe
well not technically the Nolan movies
are technically not part of this but
explain that to the fans okay well they
didn't I didn't see his face that's the
thing they didn't see his face I had a
weird voice I think sense maybe fans
will cry foul mainstream audience aren't
gonna notice I mean they may register oh
I've seen that name before buttburn oh
boy no later oh sure harms fall that's
who that was he recognized him margot
robbie is harley quinn now I don't know
I I selva seen wolf of Wall Street so I
don't NLC neither I don't know her as an
actress I've seen clips that she seem to
do quite well and I could see I've seen
clips for us all a lot of her haha yeah
I and I think that she is going when the
trailers come out she is going to be
front and center and there I think that
this is what's selling the film is
Harley I think that they are banking on
the Harley that they created an arkham
because that is the Harley that everyone
knows now I think DC is frothing at the
mouth to get Harley Quinn on the screen
and in front of audiences because I mean
just at the con how many Harley's did we
see Jack right you know hey watch it
it's like cosplay choice number one
yeah it and i think you get her in front
of a mainstream audience and they're
gonna eat her up no uh ja Jai Courtney
who is he's the new Sam Worthington
knees the news I don't know what his
nationalities but he's he's the latest
not bad button completely unremarkable
action guy of the moment if he's not
Australian or from New Zealand I'm gonna
be really upset that is a defining
aspect of Captain Boomerang that's where
boomerangs come from whoever's playing
The Enchantress which we can remember
now I mean the one thing that I feel is
worth addressing even though we can't
remember who she is our apologies we
were sure you're a fine actress and a
lovely person if we expect you to be
watching this what a financially is that
the Enchantress is an inherently magical
yes character yes and so in a way that's
going that's probably going to be this
universes first foot into flat-out magic
that's interesting to note because it
shows that dressing magic early on yep
so as they build this universe they're
not going to have to try and crowbar and
in the way that marvelous kind of had to
do okay we're getting Doctor Strange and
that's gonna be very cool right that is
flat-out magic and now they've got to
reconcile that in a well constructed
universe that up to this point just
doesn't have magic and so the way they
could cheat is she could be an
illusionist and that seems like a waste
of a world building opportunity I'm just
saying that they if they want to stay
away from magic there is a way of doing
that go ahead well except eventually
they're going to have Shazam so they've
got to get magic but at least in this
world I don't think so because they've
actually said I think they're very
clearly that Shazam is gonna exist in
his own universe no they said they're
not going to tie him into the other
movies but he's still supposed to be
existing in the same universe they're
just not going to integrate that
character the way they're integrating
everybody else another concern and this
goes back to the idea that there are
characters who have yet to be confirmed
or yet to be cast um Suicide Squad by
its nature what made it entertaining
comic reading was that the characters
died they went on missions that they
weren't expected to survive and a lot of
them didn't survive yeah
are some of these big characters that
we've seen Cass already a are some of
them fitted to die in this movie or are
we going to fill out the ranks with some
fluff characters that we see to kill
life so I could see them killing off
dead shock Will Smith he's expensive
yesterday was thinking that we guide
that's super sad and if they if they get
their money's worth out of him once and
he helps get buck gets butts in seats
they don't need him a second time right
given you this these castings um do you
feel that we're gonna get a decent film
out of this there's nobody that was cast
that I went oh that's just wrong the
pieces are in place for it to be good if
anything I'm almost the most encouraged
by this because it feels more autonomous
and more independent of the zack snyder
vision of these Justice League
characters I couldn't think of a single
casting that would make me excited about
this movie a single actor that you could
put in any one of these roles where I
would go yeah that you know I'm really
fired up because at this point I
fundamentally don't trust DC which is
unfair to judge this film out of that
but I just can't get excited about this
movie so I don't know a trailer might
turn me around right a good a good well
constructed trailer that it that clearly
demonstrates a tone and a focus could
turn me around this much like the first
trailer for guardians of the galaxy did
yep because while I didn't necessarily
think that was going to be a terrible
movie I didn't see how that was possibly
gonna work and then I saw the first
trailer I'm like okay now I'm on your
wavelength and that's probably going to
be the hinge point for me as to whether
I get interested enough to see this in
the theater or whether it becomes a hell
when I get to it yeah I'm gonna see it
it's just ya know that that that is the
classic geek conundrum yeah we can we
can feel that it's gonna so we can know
that it's gonna suck we're still gonna
say it yep and they know that and nobody
could hate somebody else nobody can hate
something as much as somebody who loved
it this is true we are geeks fear our
rack so until next time this council of
geeks is adjourned fix it in post hahaha
do we have post no no